[Applaudissements]
le but salvateur
après l' angoisse dans ce bar influence
pour le match france australie
outre les yvelinois certains supporters
viennent d'ailleurs à l'image dans droit
venu de pontoise que c'est un pote ce
qui m'a amené ici et je connais ce bar
il est très bien cris acclamation les
clients sont tendues un penalty pour la
france les mines sont rassurés une joie
de courte durée la main de titi mène un
penalty pour l'australie égalité avec la
france le doute s'installe un moment
propice pour reprendre des forces
à la 80e minute peut être la délivrance
second but pour les bleus seize minutes
de la fin moments de tension sur le
terrain comme au bar au coup de sifflet
final
quelques applaudissements pour un match
poussif c'est l'inquiétude sur les
capacités de la bande à deschamps
ah c'était pas très très bien un peu bas
et est pas très bon mais où on a kiffé
quand même le but la france a gagné sera
un derain et c'est un bon début je pense
que ça va être bon pour leur moral pour
la suite
ils étaient moins performants que les
deux premiers matches de préparation
ça ressemblait plus sot match avec les
us en attendant doute ou non la
diffusion de matchs des bleus reste une
aubaine pour les restaurateurs
c'était prévu qu'on n'ouvre pas à la
base parce que voilà il ya d'autres
d'autres établissements dans les
environs
et que bah voilà nous à base d'eau
samedi midi on est fermé et on s'était
dit qu'au dernier moment avec un certain
retour qu'on avait eu que des clans
voulait qu'on nouveau donc on a ouvert
pour eux et pour la france on va dire
donc ça très très bonnes surprises en
plus victoire de la france donc que du
bonheur prochain rendez vous pour les
supporters le 21 juin
la france affrontera le pérou